it's out
from the start of the meeting um
well
what was that yeah the live feed has
started
okay it's not actually said it on the
screen yet but there you go
right well good afternoon everyone
welcome to this afternoon's meeting of
the standards committee
this meeting is open to the public and
has been streamed live
to youtube by the council's website
it has also been recorded for the
purpose of the minutes
if for any reason the public can no
longer hear
or see the meeting of the live spree we
will adjourn
until the connection has been
re-established
i would like to remind members of
meeting etiquette that has been
circulated
and the procedures that apply for remote
attendees
all members should have their
microphones muted
and cameras turned on members are
reminded that you must remain
on camera throughout the meeting and
ensure you are alone
in the room okay
right item one apologies for absence
uh so are we early at the moment um
but so uh have we only
apologize that have been received
or something and any from the floor
there's apologies from councillor um
derrick skinner and councillor diana
ruff chair
right thank you
right item two declarations of interest
do members have any interest to declare
no right item three
uh minutes of the last meeting
can we approve the minutes of the last
meeting as a true
and accurate record chair can i just
come in please on this before it's
actually agreed
i did put my apologies in for that
meeting because i was in hospital that
day
and obviously i'm not on there's an
apology
okay and the clock
uh please record that
right so is there a is there a mover
i'm happy to move chair that's uh
council hancock
and a secondary second
right patankle right thank you very much
uh right
so can we have a vote them
all in favor
right so that's uh any against
and the abstentions so the melting's
being carried
okay right
item four joint whistle blowing
policy annual report can i invite the
governance manager
to present the report under the joint
whistleblowing policy
thank you chair um this policy is
essentially the same document
that you approved at this time last year
and however it has been reviewed to
ensure that it is
fit for purpose um so it's brought
forward to you today
uh for your approval um as it would be
done on an annual basis but with no
amendments
suggested from last year um
furthermore the monitoring officer she's
obliged to report you on an annual basis
any instances of whistleblowing
and as you see in 2.2 no instances are
reported within the last 12 months
so i'm happy to take any queries any
members have chair
any questions from members
no okay is there a move before the
recommendations
are set out in 6.1 of the report
council hancock is there a seconder
everybody
right uh all in favor
okay nobody against
right any abstentions no well
the emotions being carried
right uh item five independent
room rumination panel
if i can say it correctly can i write
the
governance manager to present the report
on the independent remuneration panel
thank you chair and as members will be
aware members allowances for this
authority are index linked to staff pay
so on that basis it's best practice to
review the levels of allowances
every four years um with the last review
for this authority taking place within
the 2016-17
municipal year so it's very timely the
report is brought to standards to advise
you
that comedian irp is not only timely but
also appropriate and invites
members to share thoughts they may have
around the types of persons who might be
suitable to sit on such a panel
and some suggestions for your
consideration are set out at 2.1 in your
report
thank you chair thank you uh
right uh any questions
we've all been very quiet today
about david's cat doesn't even come yet
right is there a move for the
recommendations then
nobody wants to move it
yeah i've seen your car right that's
cathy rose
a second to please pat hancliff
so the vote all in favor
[Music]
right uh any against
any abstentions
right the motion has been carried
right item six the local government
association
model code of conduct can i ask the
monetary
officer to present the report on the lga
model gold of conduct thank you chair
as members are aware the lga the local
government association consulted on a
model code of conduct last year
this followed the committee for
standards in public life's report on the
ethical framework in local government
it was felt as a result of that work
that there needed to be more structure
and uniformity in the codes of conduct
applied in local government hence the
model
we've now got that final version through
which is what you have before you
in terms of what we've found with some
particular parish councils we've found
that they have very simple codes this
can cause us issues and trying to
administer
complaints and it also makes it very
difficult for members when they haven't
got the similar
code to comply with when we have the
district's final version i will be
promoting it to parish councils
i'll write out to them inviting them to
use the version that the district will
be likely to agree
the intention today is to go through the
draft get members comments and come back
to standards committee in april with a
final draft
this will then be recommended to the
annual meeting for adoption
following that there will be training
for district councils we're looking
uh putting together actively putting
together a midterm
member induction scheme for may june
later in the year but we'll also be
looking at what training we can give to
parish councils and parish councillors
we thought it was worth going through
this section by section
but we're going to share out the talking
so i'll start but the others will come
in with various sections
it starts with a joint statement which i
think sets the position out very well
but the only thing i would suggest there
is that we perhaps had something from
the district council's perspective
of why the district council thinks it's
important as well
so that's one of the drafting
possibilities we have
the introduction on uh page 217
it's the same pages is also
self-explanatory but again
i'm inclined to add something from
district council's perspective saying
uh what we wanted to say about reviews
etc
[Music]
the definitions are i think perfectly
obvious
the purpose of the code section makes it
clear it's about you as
counselors ensuring your own behavior is
acceptable
and it does encourage support which i
would re-emphasize
from any deputy monitoring officer
governments and legal with any issues
you have in relation
to the code it then goes on to have a
cancer conduct uh section
i'm sorry i thought it was a question um
it quotes the nolan principles
those are in appendix a we've always had
the nolan principles in the code of
conduct
and i would be minded to put them in not
as an appendix but in the body of the
code
probably somewhere in this section here
it then goes on to outline its general
principles accounts of conduct i don't
think anything there
is a surprise um the code as a whole
does seem to be paying uh placing more
emphasis on
uh respect and not bullying um
as i'm sure you're aware this is
particularly an issue in some parts of
the country with
parish and town councils so that's
presumably what they're targeting
the application of the code is an area
where they're trying
to widen its applicability without
changing the legislation the case law at
the moment stands that code only applies
to counsellors when acting as
counsellors
this is trying to this is extending it
to where you hold yourselves out where
you
give the impression that you're acting
as a counsellor
now where we draw the line is going to
be very much dependent on circumstances
etc so we can't give
pre-ideas of what that will be but we
will look to put some examples
together in the package with the draft
code so we can have a look at that issue
but it is important to know that it's
widening it
and i think it's over to kev
thank you sarah i'm turning then to the
specific standards of council of conduct
and these are
the uh provisions which uh greece
which could see you subject to a
complaint an action being taken
the first of these is respect now
um this is something that has appeared
in existing codes
um in brief and without much guidance
the new uh model code provides a clearer
explanation of what respect is and it
explains where better where the limits
lie between political debate and
disrespect
and it focuses particularly on when one
be when the former becomes
personal uh attacks on individuals
or groups um the other thing that's
included
is some guidance on how to handle
disrespectful behavior towards
yourselves as counselors
so that's something that's new
and moving on the second point is
bullying harassment and discrimination
again it significantly expands on on all
three of these
uh compared to previous codes
in the guidance that it gives and it
roots all three of those
in the relevant legal background
uh so it talks about a cast when he
talks about bullying
and then that links into how bullying's
a matter of
impact and perception rather than the
intention of the person that's doing it
um and the
harassment and discrimination uh
provisions are rooted in the relevant
legislation
and interestingly it also flags up the
equalities act
duties that are placed on the council as
an authority and reminds
councillors that your conduct could
potentially place the council itself at
risk
for breaching the equalities act um
i think nikki's picking up section three
yes thank you um so in regard to
impartiality members will be familiar
with the themes within this section
because it very much minimizes how this
is defined within your existing member
officer protocol
um however it does have additional
emphasis in regard to forcibly
altering content of advice or reports
back to me i think for section four
um just looking at confidentiality
and access to information again uh
compared to previous uh codes he's got
clearer guidance for counselors
and reflects up-to-date practice on the
current data protection law
it addresses the requirement not to
disclose confidential information
accepting limited circumstances
uh including whistle blowing uh
it also addresses misuse of any
information that that councillors may
obtain
as part of their role and finally it
makes it clear that council is
obstructing public access
to information they should have it would
also be uh
each thank you
okay then we get to section five
disrepute
it's re-emphasizing here that council is
judged by the public
as to what they do and we all know that
the public doesn't necessarily see a
bar between your private life and your
actions as a counselor
so in some ways you're not as free as
private individuals because of your your
actions reflect on the council's
reputation
but when doing anything as a counselor
or giving the impression that you're
acting as a counselor
you should consider whether it's the
right thing to do whether it's compliant
with code and other rules
and whether it has any reputational
impact
the next section is use of position this
is not at all you and this just reflects
that you act for the community
and what you're doing should be on
behalf of the public
rather than your own interests i think
it's over to nikki
yeah so um if i can refer you to part
seven which is um
a section on local authority resources
um as with
other elements of this code the contents
are mirrored elsewhere within your
constitution
and for this matter it's as described
within your members allowance scheme
albeit with details of what might be
considered a resource and it does give
you
examples uh which we don't have
currently
in uh in regard to complying with the
code of conduct at point eight
and as you'll be aware all members and
co-optees are asked to sign up to the
code of conduct when they're appointed
however this provision within the new
model code is
more explicit where it states um that
you will undertake
training as provided on the code of
conduct by the local authority
and that's already detailed within your
code of conduct within
intimidate any persons involved in the
proceedings and eight
four to comply with any sanction imposed
um
finding uh if there is a finding that
that a breach has been made
in regard to section nine on
interests your code of conduct currently
is very detailed in regard to interest
so
this section here provides a proceed but
then refers to dealing with actions to
take in regard to interests
into an appendix which might be a better
way of setting it out
and then finally from me uh the section
on gifts and hospitality the example
given here
um is rather generic of course and it
would when
it comes back to you as part of a new
code of conduct
your rules around gifts and hospitality
the levels that you have previously set
would be included within there
and however the boarding within the
model code does provide you with more
clarity
but it is in tune with your current
arrangements
thank you so chair basically
it's anything that members would like us
to include or further explain
before we come back with a draft to the
next meeting
right thank you for that uh
no doubt there's uh lots to go through
here
uh i did notice the top 10.2
i understand that it used to be 25
pounds or something
uh hospitality it wasn't one stage yes
right so we've had a rise of we know
like the current constitution states
that it's 25 pounds currently
right okay so uh until it's voted on
uh then it's uh it goes up to 59
to take the new one if members wish yes
right right any questions then
it's rather a lot to digest all in one
go i must admit
and chair that's partly why we've
brought it now with you to bring in a
draft in april
so that if anybody has any thoughts
about it when they've
taken it in they can email email one of
us
and ask us and we'll try and incorporate
whatever is necessary in the draft
okay ah
councillor hancock yes
thank you chair um this this might just
be me with
with the way i've historically read
contracts which i know it's not a
contract but it's it kind of
same format but on on section 4
i would have thought under 4a we should
also have the provision
um some of the provisions that we've
gotten before b
um because if information is given to us
in confidence but we're really required
to disclose that legally um then i would
thought
that should be there um
chair yeah i see your point and we'll
look at that as part of the drafting see
if we need to include that in that way
thank you thank you
[Music]
council bangkok sorry chair it's just
this is a rarely mine a bit but i'm
thinking from the perspective of
parishes here
under 8.1 um which is obviously about
the training um obviously
a lot of parishioners have quite a small
budget and
um is this something that
would be available free to them because
it wouldn't necessarily be as affordable
to them as it is to us
if if they were to adopt our our
standard code
well myself i think it should be the
same as
our training it should be free of charge
uh i don't know what anybody else thinks
as as chair as the monitoring officer
would always try and provide that
training one way or another
via the monitoring officer and we don't
charge
brilliant thank you uh i must
actually declare an interest on this
because
i'm vice president of doubt who were
charged for their training
but there you go
right any more interests
any more questions at the moment
right okay then uh
is there a mover for the recommendations
uh council hancock and a second
uh you've got cathy ross
right clever vote then all those in
favor
okay any against
any abstentions okay so the
uh motion is carried
right so item seven
now vacating office go to practice
we will now consider a proposed code of
practice
for the application of the six-month
rule
can i remind members that we are in open
session
and therefore refrain refrain from
referring to
any individuals or personal
and sensitive information can i invite
the governance manager
to present the report
thank you chair and so it's been
identified that this authority doesn't
currently have a documented code of
practice for managing the processes when
a member vacates office and that can be
for many different ways which are
detailed within that code
and although we do have a way of working
that has been in place for
for a while um in relation to this
matter
um the code of practice um advises of
the legislative
requirements um in regard to this matter
and gives context to some of the
arrangements in place
for the actions the authority will take
in instances where a member
vacates the uh vacates their office
um one thing to add to to the um
to the report is that in briefing we
identified that co-opted members were
not included as part of this code
um and it was queried on whether the
section 85
rule or the six month rule um applied to
collective members
which it does not so what i have drawn
up uh for members consideration today
are some suggested
editions um and with your permission
chair i will um
i will table those auditions to the
members and go through them
um are you happy for me to do that chair
yes yes go ahead
okay i will just um i will just share my
screen
go with me one moment just to make sure
i get the right screen
in front and just adjust my settings
here so that we can all
see it um so so this is the code that
you've got in front of you
um and there's a suggestion that there's
an edition
put in at 1.7 where it states that
as i've explained in reference to a
collected member section 85 and section
86 of the local government act do not
apply
and neither um does the lgha um
so a culture member may vacate office
when they choose to do so through
resignation
um certainly when they die or where the
council removes them by resolution
um if i go further down um
within the code there is there is a
typographical error you may see in your
code in regard to the numbering i do
apologize that will be
um amended and it's an additional
two points at the end of section two
which i've put 2.8 and 2.9
um where a committee or outside body to
which the council has appointed a
co-opted member wishes to replace
its nominee the matter will be referred
to council
council alone can determine whether to
receive the request
and that this matter will be considered
in private session
of course it would be uh in regard to
you that would be under schedule 12a
and that um an example for a reason for
replacement could be a sustained
non-attendance or non-contact um
one final addition would be
within section five which just notes of
course everything else would be the same
but when it comes to um issuing a
vacancy
that this matter would be dealt with
within governance so in case of a coptic
member the governance manager
would manage the replacement
i'm happy to take any questions chair
right any questions counselor hancock
all right chair struggling with the mute
option there uh i just have actually one
concern with it
um nicky if if i could suggest it and
possibly suggest an amendment
um and that's that's to 3.1
um where we're saying a request for
dispensation
or extension for dispensation is made in
writing to the monitoring officer or her
deputy from the member concerned
and i think that should be something
that's preferable
but i can think of quite a few instances
where
it may not be possible for the member
themselves to do it
and i think we should open the scope
that someone else may be able to do it
on their behalf
um and i say i can think of certain
medical issues that would prevent
someone from from perhaps doing it
themselves
and i think we need to be mindful of
particular circumstances
yes i think i i agree with you you know
there are people
who i don't know if they've had a
serious operation
and they can't actually do for
themselves they can
uh get somebody to do it for
them uh but this would have to be
somebody who is approved and has got
full
approval uh from them how they would do
it quite uh
throw it open to the governance and
see what sort of grounds they could do
okay uh fat caring
yes cam there were several things within
this that gave me
uh cause for concern you know
we're said to be a caring counsel and
this report goes
entirely against this if a member
doesn't
inform the council six weeks before the
six month period they can lose their
right to be a member
just like that as a citizen of the
council
uh retinal homes would have a discussion
about
rent areas prior to eviction council tax
department would notify arrears before
the bailiffs are sent in
as an employer would be spoken to by the
human resources or line manager
uh before dismissal but as an elected
member it's entirely incumbent on them
to make representation
and already it might be difficult to
make representation
in certain circumstances
uh the scenario doesn't often happen
and when it does it often uh as a result
of unusual circumstances
grave illness uh severe trauma
uh mental deterioration
uh you know
there are lots of reasons why it might
be difficult
what concerns me most of all and i can
see why they probably do it
is over on four uh
four the government's
team do monitor attendance however
they will not approach a member in
regard to the expiry of a six-month rule
this is not
this is members legal responsibility i'm
shouldered by the local authority
i'm sure somewhere along the line
that isn't a very caring attitude
i i think uh they do
want to monitor it uh there are lots of
reasons it doesn't happen very often
that a member runs out of time
and it's generally under very severe
circumstances
and i do think somewhere along the line
that they could monitor
and give a heads up to the
individual member that is getting close
or give the heads up
to a representative of the political
parties
that we're in you know uh the leader of
the conservatives
leader of the labor at this stage
as a member i i think
when we're not an employee of the
council
and we're not uh we're not just a
citizen
uh we're part and parcel of the whole
process
and i don't think it's hanging us out to
dry i can see why they probably
don't want to do it in case they forgot
it would be their fault and not
our fault but i think somewhere along
the line
there should be some help with that i
can quote
several circumstances but you know i
don't want to bring any sort of names
into it i think we all know
but i will have great difficulty as a
member
not you know i would like that to go
back for rethought uh just somewhere
where there could be a prompt uh towards
somebody to help a member who's perhaps
in great difficulty
or or not it would be sad to get long
covered
and be under the uh put out
of the in in a new induced coma
for three months and wake up to find
because you hadn't written the letter
uh you don't get dispensation
and you know i i didn't like it i i just
thought somewhere
as a caring counsel we should
have some responsibility or
a way that we could tell the members
that that or somebody that represents
the members
that this could happen i would have
great difficulty
in taking a voting for this as it stands
at the moment
sorry i've woken up it's not very often
i wake up but i have today
oh thank you thank you for that i must
admit uh
when you're looking at these poor people
in hospital with an induced coma
uh with covid yes i agree with
everything that you say there must be
some way
of uh letting somebody know either
the leader of a political party or
somebody a representative a spouse or
something like that
that they are they're running short of
time let's put it like that
and perhaps i could ask the
monitor to come in on this please thank
you
um as you know i'm a lawyer and the
legal position is it's the members
individual responsibility whether or not
we were to alert people alert members
that would not take away from that
responsibility it would still be the
individual members responsibility
i hear what you say we have to
do the right thing we will have a look
at it for you if that's what you want
us to do but i can't change the
responsibility ultimately the
responsibility is the individual members
we can of course as has been suggested
by council hancock
accept letters etc on behalf of the
person if they're too ill
to do it themselves that's not an issue
we can do that
but in terms of the responsibility it is
the individual
and i don't want to sound aggressive or
anything but the
reason for this provision is about
representation
if you haven't had some if somebody
hasn't been for six months
they may well have good cause but that's
still six months for their public their
voters
and their non-voters indeed in their
area have not had representation
and that's what he's dealing with rather
than with the individual counselor
i suppose what i'm coming around to
saying is we'll look at it anything we
do will not be in the
code it will be beside the code
right would you be happy with that part
counselor kerry would you would you be
happy if we have a little look at it
that that's what i was asking paul uh
you know i i was suggesting that we
refer it back to see
if something on those lines
um on an ad hoc basis could be included
yeah yeah come yes sir
sorry just to come back the last thing i
said we couldn't have something on the
face of the code because the legal
position is
but it's the members responsibility what
i was talking about is what we can do in
the background
right so uh there is a way around it uh
on the
in the background should we put it like
that possibly
right we will actively look at that
well for myself i think it does need
looking at
and to try and make it uh
what shall i say easier for a member
even if they are sort of
comatose at the time
right any other questions
no right
can we uh approve
the uh uh
the proposed code of conduct from the
district council
uh vacating office is the remover please
uh chair is that including my amendment
or
yes yes yes i'm happy to move with the
amended version
right a second
yeah so cancel ankly
right uh could we have a vote then all
those in favor
okay
all against
any abstentions
okay
so do we have a result there then
the motions carried that do i take it
okay right if we move to
item eight that's the protocol for the
ordeal stroke vizio footage at meetings
could i ask the government's manager to
present the proposed
code of practice for audio and visual
footage of proper meetings
thank you chair in the same vein as the
last report has been identified the
authority doesn't have a code of
practice written down in regard to this
although we have a practice that we do
use
locally um i'd like to draw your
attention in particular
to uh section three within the code
um where it does set out at 3.1 there's
no requirement to hold a back catalog
of the meetings um although we would
leave the video footage on youtube to
increase
access to democracy and transparency for
decision making
3.2 a statement where the footage is
exempt
it will not be live streamed um
3.3 where the footage displays behavior
the monitoring
officer and the chair of standards in
consultation deemed to be offensive to
the public anyway
this would be removed and edited and
re-uploaded
minus the offensive footage it would
only be editing of sound rather than
video
where possible um furthermore um this
code of practice has been amended to
make sure that it does supply
where um where we're in a state um
of the pandemic where we're operating
under virtual meetings but it also
um goes on to have its applicability
when uh when in person meetings may
return uh to ask members to comply with
the requirements of the constitution
thank you chair
thank you any questions
right uh just a couple of them
you're muted
i can't hear you yes
no you can you hear me now yes
yes uh i just i know the chair at the
beginning of the meeting reminded people
if they were taking any
exempt that we be you know
a room on their own and i wonder if this
sort of advice should actually be
contained within this code of practice
written down in other words
because it is possible that you can have
other people actually in the room and
then not be on camera so you can't see
them
you know just to sort of remind people
that that you know that they have a
a responsibility to treat exempt and
confidential items you know as
confidential
to everybody including other members of
the household who may
be present or nearby and i did wonder
whether that
might be something that could be just
written down i know we reminded people
at the beginning chair
but i don't see it written down in the
case of virtual meetings i'm talking
about
nikki could you come in please on that
thank you
uh yes um we have uh the etiquette which
we used
for virtual meetings which is mentioned
and referred to within this document
at um 3.4 and within that educa it does
set out quite clearly
how members should behave when operating
in virtual meetings and it does give
advice
and guidance to members about being at
home in regard to exempt information and
also talks about
devices uh listening and recording
devices such as
an amazon echo that can often pick up
conversations to not have those in the
room
so that's quite detailed and referred to
um
obviously if members wish for that to be
made explicitly in this public practice
of course
that would that that can happen um
although it is referred to
and it is written down elsewhere
is that uh all right for you uh uh
patricia coleman
oh yes yes i just i you know i just i
just thought it was worth mentioning
that so thank you
thank you uh david hancock i saw your
hand
thank you chair yeah i mean i agree with
90 percent of this i just have
huge concerns over 3.3 um
because i i understand that perfectly
in terms of editing to remove anything
which is confidential which may be
disclosed and i think that that's that's
obviously appropriate thing to do
um but i think when we're coming down to
what individuals deem as offensive
um and don't particularly like is
is is removing an element of democracy
and
and i mean to be fair and whether this
is just
me and obviously when we're reading
these things it's always open to
individual interpretation isn't it but
what we're saying here political rough
and tumble will not be deemed as
offensive
i mean that there are certain members
who i find quite offensive in terms of
what they come out with at times
and then when we go back to the code of
conduct
we've actually got in the new code of
conduct there's actually reference
um under in the paragraph under 1.2
um which actually says you should not
however subject individuals groups of
people or organizations to personal
attack
so potentially some of the stuff that we
are possibly classing as political rough
and tumble
where one group or organization is
slating another one
would actually fall foul of the new code
of conduct
um but we're saying in somebody's
opinion that may not actually be
offensive so
i think i think we we should take that
out i mean if people are misbehaving
they're misbehaving
um and i understand that i mean ready as
councillors we're responsible for our
own conduct
and not bringing the council into
disrepute i don't
really think that we should be then
removing footage it's up to
up to the public whether they feel that
person is then a
an appropriate person to continue
representing them in the future
i think this is uh oh uh if we could
have sarah
yes um yeah we i think we all know where
this comes from
the issue is on that particular point
that if we don't remove some of these
things we run the risk that the whole
recording will be taken down
and that's a principal driver so
uh in terms of what the chair and i
would look at
or chair and my deputy would look at is
this something that's likely to bring
the recording down if somebody complains
i think that's
where we're getting to and that's the
risk
sorry i'm echoing there would it be
possible sarah to actually
expand on this a little bit and put down
predefined criteria
and say it ticks this box or it doesn't
so it becomes much less
apparently subjective i think i'd be
more comfortable with that if we had
hard and fast
fast criteria to be honest that would
suit me as well because the less
subjective it is the better i
agree we'll have a look at putting some
criteria thank you
okay any more questions on that
so as it stands you're going to have a
look at the criteria
for next time yes chair
right thank you right uh
any more questions
no right uh is a remover for the
recommendations including the
bits that need uh further investigation
no one wants to move it yeah david will
okay so it's councillor hancock uh
to move it and the second pat ankly
right
uh could have the boat please all those
in favor
all against
any abstentions
okay so that motions being carried
right item nine
uh reveal the constitution part four
can i ask the monetary officer to
present the reporter on the review of
the council's constitution
part four uh chair am i doing this are
you doing this nikki
i'm happy to take it sir thank you um
so this is part of your review of the
constitution as you know this
report of some kind comes to each
meeting of the standards committee in
this the
fourth one of the municipal year um at
part three it sets out in the first
section
of the table the shaded elements are
areas of the constitution you've already
considered through the standards
committee
um the second set um is the unshaded
is what's going to come forward for
discussion at this meeting
and then uh this the last section of
shaded
uh um areas are those that will be
forthcoming either
at your april meeting or into the new
municipal year
um also we do make note at 1.4
um of those areas of the constitution
that went directly to council
we put this in the report just for
completeness and just for you to note
but really i'd like to take members
straight into the appendix which is is
the bulk of the information of which
you'd probably wish to
consider and discuss today um there are
a few areas of the constitution are
brought forward
for you to look at the first being um a
change to
the contract procurement rules um with
a suggestion to raise a request for
quotation can be used in place of
tenders
um this is currently at fifty thousand
pounds and it's um
it's suggested by the pyramid team to
increase this
to seventy five thousand pounds um
they're suggesting this change
and in order to help local businesses
um and this is particularly important
because the pandemic's effect on
the local economy chair
are you happy for me to go through all
the changes or would you like to discuss
each change
as we present uh
if you go through each of it
please thank you chair in which case
i'll move on then to
extraordinary council meetings um this
is just an error
of clarity so this will this doesn't
necessarily need voting on this is just
for members to know that the monitoring
officer as part of her housekeeping
of the constitution will add a footnote
into 3.3 to add some additional clarity
in regard to
how um extraordinary council meetings
are called
the third that item is in regard to
delegations
to environmental health offices and
there's a delegation that already exists
that is given to the head of planning
and the planning manager um
in regard to uh service section 215 of
the town and country coming at
1990 notices um and it's proposed that
that
delegation has extended the
environmental health officers
who usually are the instigators for the
action that we're talking about there
um the next change um is
uh in regard to a matter that we've
already considered on today's agenda
which is that pride of practice for
vacating office
so this is um a suggestion to add a
delegation
um to the monetary officer to provide a
dispensation
in instances where an application for
dispensation is received
we're not able to hold a council meeting
um
in time for that i think this was um an
issue which
counselor kerry raised during the
consideration of that matter
that actually there may be there may be
instances where
a member is not able to um let the
authority know
that they require dispensation and this
uh
this delegation to the monitoring
officer would allow the monitoring
officer to make
a dispensation for a short period of
time
in which to allow council to consider
that dispensation
the next one second to last is uh the
review of the see uh cjcc
and there are some minor amendments
suggested which are set out in appendix
2
hopefully we'll be able to answer any
queries if you have on those
they've been considered by the committee
themselves prior to coming to you today
and the final uh proposal for change is
that when we take the review of the
constitutional report to council each
year
we add an extra delegation within the
report that the monitoring officer can
make any changes to the constitution
if there's any new legislation that
comes up in year if there's any
administrative errors
or corrections in interpretation and
it's proposed that we just add this to
the delegation scheme to save members
happy to vote on the same issue
year on year happy to take any questions
where i can share
right are there any questions
councillor hancock
sorry struggling with the mute again um
i agree with
i agree with 99 of this and i just
really it's a clarification because you
know when you can see something going
massively wrong and blown up in people's
faces and i just want to stop that
the the bit about the section 85 um
a bit um i'm assuming
that that it's going to be so that the
monitoring officer isn't put in a
position that would
create all sorts of potential problems
for her down the line
that should that position arise it would
be an
automatic dispensation until the next
meeting so that obviously nobody came
pointing fingers and saying well sarah
didn't do this
yes uh if i might say counseling you're
entirely right
it would be no decision you just
automatically do it
any more questions
no okay well uh
can we support the submission of the
proposals
to the council as part of the
constitution review
could we have a mover please council
hancock
and the seconder
uh councillor and cliff
can we ever show hanse all in favor
any against
any extensions right so the motion's
been carried
right correa
item 10 the complete update canada
i invite the monitoring officer to
update the committee on complaints
thank you chair um after a bit of a
rough passage and with
um kev coming in as deputy monitoring
officer we've managed to get through
quite a lot of these
the current currently we have six
outstanding complaints
uh from five from 2020 with two district
council and three
parish council related and one from 2021
which is district council related
they're all pretty much nearing the end
of their
consideration thank you chair okay
can we agree to note the update
is remover
council hancock and a second a
right-hand clue
all in favor
any against
any abstentions
all the motion has been carried
right uh now then the
uh work programme can i invite the
governance officer to present the
committee's
work program for the remainder of the
municipal year
uh thank you chair the report just
outlines the committee's work programme
um for the remainder of the municipal
year
excuse me um it's a rolling document um
and it's
subject to change as members see fit and
so it's really just a committee just to
note and approve the word program
any questions
okay could we have a mover please
uh pat handcliff and the seconder
david hancock all in favor
only against
any abstentions right so the motion has
been
carried right
item 12 uh urgent business
uh i have no uh urgent business
uh but uh apart from one thing now then
yes
i mustn't forget this the meeting
on i think it's the 24th
of uh
21st wednesday the 21st of april
uh i've moved it to three o'clock
because i'm having my co-word job just
before
two so uh if you don't want to be
addressed by
a bumbling idiot
that's the reason i've moved it so you
still may
get a mumbling idiot then
depending how it goes so if there's
nothing else
i declare the meeting close and thank
you all very much for coming along
and uh don't forget it's a three o'clock
start
okay thank you
you